[Music]
it began as a holiday eager to escape a
bright future on the Great Plains arthur
howitzer jr. transformed the series of
travelogue columns into the french
dispatch a factual weekly report on the
subjects of world politics the arts high
and low and diverse stories of human
interest you don't think it's almost too
seedy this time no i don't see some
people supposed to be charming you
assembled a team of the best patriot
journalists of his time Berenson Sazerac
Crimmins Roebuck write these for his
people just try to make it sound like
you wrote it that way on purpose we take
as the subject of tonight's lecture mr.
Moses Rosenthal certainly the loudest
autistic voice of his rowdy generation
simone naked cellblock J Hobby room I
want to buy it isn't uh for sale yes it
is yes it is yes for this yes in short
the picture was a sensation
the kids did this
obliterated a thousand years of
Republican Authority in less than 420
what do they want freedom full stop uh
naked mrs. Crimmins I can see them
lieutenant Nescafe is the great exemplar
of the mold of cuisine known as police
cooking the aromas of the kitchen cast a
smell which was to be mortally broken as
you know by now we have kidnapped your
son
[Music]
[Music]
a message from the foreman one hour to
press you're fired
don't cry in my office
[Applause]
[Music]